salut en ce moment j'enchaîne les
spectacles les projets les vidéos et
c'est le bordel chez moi un truc de
dingue tu es pas tout à fait logique
parce que je suis plutôt maniaque par
exemple en anecdotes rigolotes pour mon
anniversaire j'ai commandé un
sèche-linge tu vois le genre de cadeau
que tout le monde aime ça c'est vraiment
fun
aujourd'hui je pense que la vidéo soit
un petit peu rapide ce n'est pas très
grave puisque les dernières était plutôt
longue mais c'est surtout parce que je
viens de lire une série d'articles sur
lequel je pèche pas forcément un avis
très construit mais j'aimerais bien
partager ça avec vous on va parler de
l'effet mouton chèvre générique c'est un
petit peu par darling parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va parler un petit peu
de psy et pas de psychologie de pouvoirs
psy ou de pouvoir potentiellement de si
c'est pas rare de voir des gens qui
prétendent avoir des pouvoirs psy ne pas
réussir à le faire quand on leur demande
ou dans des conditions de laboratoire et
la grande excuses c'est de dire oui mais
là il ya des gens qui n'y croient pas
donc forcément ça ça ne fonctionne pas
avec eux entre ces petits qu'ils
envoient de mauvaises énergies
donc mon pouvoir ne peut pas se met en
place et on a l'impression que c'est une
bonne excuse pour tout justifier tout et
n'importe quoi en tout cas pour les
personnes rationnelles comme moi je dis
bah est trop facile de dire ça et puis
là je suis tombé sur un article et j'ai
été faire un peu plus de recherches je
vous mets le lien de toutes ses sources
dans la description si vous voulez lire
ça vous aussi et c'est intéressant ça me
fait pas forcément changé d'avis mais
c'est intéressant de l' hypothèse serait
que le scepticisme soit donc une force
mentale et un pouvoir sur un résultat
psy gertrude shdm et de l'air en 1957 a
tenté un test
oui on tente un test à la tester un test
à new york où elle exerçait en tant que
professeur de psychologie à la city
university
elle a créé deux groupes deux groupes
d'élèves il ya un groupe qui croyait aux
pouvoirs psy à l'existence de ce
phénomène est un groupe qui ne croyait
pas du tout qui était complètement
sceptiques il y avait des élèves y avait
des gens normaux ce qu'elle voulait
c'était d'avoir vraiment les convaincus
d'un côté et les rationnels qui refuse
toute possibilité de pouvoir psy de
l'autre et pour son projet me demandez
pas pourquoi j'ai cherché durant une
demi journée je ne trouve pas pourquoi
elle a appelé ceux qui croyaient au
pouvoir si les moutons et ceux qui n'y
croyaient pas les chèvres et elle a fait
passer aux personnes de ces groupes le
test deux nerfs avec les cartes esp vous
savez c'est les cartes vous avait déjà
parlé
donc il ya le cercle des toiles la croix
le carré et les vagues étaient juste
cinq symboles qui sont répétés cinq fois
sur 25 cartes
et on prend l'une des cartes et la
personne en face elle qui est testé doit
deviner quel carton à la main on peut
faire l'expérience ensemble concentrez
vous délaissez elle que j'ai dans les
mains
g g d'après vous concentrez vous j'ai la
vague une chance sur cinq pour que vous
ayez bon le test deux nerfs se fait un
peu comme on veut par exemple avec les
25 cartes et on note et on va comparer
ce qu'on aurait avec le hasard puisque à
chaque fois il ya une chance sur cinq
d'avoir la carte plus ya de cartes qui
sont passés plus on a de chance de
trouver la bonne carte externe ce qui
est ou demandant les résultats de notre
ami gertrude c'est que les moutons ceux
qui croyaient aux effets psy lui des
résultats significatifs
c'est à dire de nombreux succès plus que
la ligne de base du hasard alors que les
chèvres les rationnels sont restés sur
la ligne de base du hasard il n'y a pas
eu de différence
on a donné un nom à cet effet c'est
resté sous le nom de l'effet mouton
chèvre et en 1975 marvin est le mood à
essayer d'améliorer un petit peu le
protocole de gertrude jeudi son prénom à
chaque fois que les noms de famille sont
compliquées jeudi le prénom après et a
fait son propre test pour faire une
comparaison
et les résultats ont été un peu ou fait
puisque on a eu à peu près les mêmes
résultats que dans le texte initial
mais il ya une encore différence les
chèvres ceux qui ne croient pas du tout
dans les pouvoirs s'ils ont eu des
résultats tellement mauvais tellement
nulle tellement d'erreurs qu'ils étaient
en dessous largement en dessous de la
ligne de base du hasard dire que en
répondant au pif
on est censé à avoir meilleur résultat
que ce qu'ils ont eu peu espèce de
validation inversée de leurs propres
croyances on peut lire ça dans le
journal of american society of
psychologique cole ricerche je crois je
vous mets dans la description alors
beaucoup de personnes ont donné leur
avis par rapport à ça dont eric bigamie
etc mais ce sont des personnes qui sont
de base convaincu que les pouvoirs s'ils
existent mais ce qui est très étonnant
c'est que les chèvres face d'aussi bons
résultats dans leur croyance c'est à
dire le fait qu'ils ratent énormément et
une réussite en soi puisqu'il ont défié
le hasard pour aller sous la ligne de
base du hasard pour correspondre à ce
qu'ils pensent eux le fait que ça ne
fonctionne pas c'est une réussite mais
une réussite inversée alors quel est mon
avis là dessus me demanderez-vous je
voulais dit au début de la vidéo j'ai
pas forcément d'avis dessus surtout que
j'ai pas pu lire plus de choses que ça
il faudrait voir ça aujourd'hui dans des
conditions aujourd'hui des conditions de
labo voir ce que ça représenterait
peut-être que l'année prochaine
je ferai une vidéo là dessus j'aimerais
bien reprendre ce test faire peut-être
rappelle à vous les abonnés et faire un
test dans ce sens le but sera pas de
prouver quoi que ce soit mais de de
reprendre le protocole nous mêmes pour
le faire et voir ce que ça donne
si vous êtes partant sur l'idée partant
pour participer mais telle mois dans les
commentaires c'est une vidéo qu'on
pourrait se faire en janvier ou en
février
encore une fois il aurait pas de
jugement particulier de croire ou pas
aux effets petit mais d'avoir deux
groupes de personnes qui pensent
différemment et de faire le test est de
voir un peu ce qui se passe
alors ça vous tente comme toujours
penser à la ligue et la vidéo à vous
abonner si ça vous a plu
et rendez vous demain à 17h ciao j'aime
bien attendre pour voir s'il y en a qui
reste un tout petit peu plus longtemps
jusqu'au bout du bout du bout du bout si
c'est ça alors vous êtes des vrais chao
vous
[Musique]